Here are five ways telegram is used to secure
"phone number" in the way it's worn
Now the methods to be described are the telegram's pyramid
Ann.
Stay put out of the settings.
To the others on the telegram
You can wear it so that you can't look at your phone number
IF YOU DO THIS YOU GET INTO THE PHONE CASE
When it's over and you give awake body a choice but you get it
You can hide being online so others don t see it
okay if you've been given a wake-up body online for a long time
GO AWAY!
just your profile picture
You can also hide it on telegram so that other strangers don't see it,
This is also in the short profile
Pick mi countess and you get it
You can also make sure you can't call other unknown strangers,
At Costco: "Give the wake body the pick.
"
Then nobody's gonna be able to call anymore
It's not.
If you want me to be able to call those people
in the constant who have a phone note
If you pick mi kwon tanks you get it.
Also I made my account unaccessible from both phone and message
i was on my message saying that the person i was talking
to was gonna make a mix of the phone to someone else
In order to prevent it, it's okay if you have it because both
the phone and the message have been given a wake-up body